I'm going to talk about node so briefly
so notice is a server-side j/s platform
it's built on Google's v8 it does it I
Oh in a very special way which I will
describe in great detail it uses the
common J's module system and it's
written in C which has confused a lot of
people so it's a rather large C project
actually so the thesis is that IO has to
be done differently we're doing it wrong
everything the way that we're thinking
about doing IO really makes things
difficult so writing servers and writing
any sort of application is difficult
because of how we're doing
io so a lot of web applications have
such line of code like you query a
database and then you return a result
and then you use the result and so the
question is what is your web framework
doing well that while this line of code
is running so in many cases you're not
doing anything at all you're just
sitting there while the database is
waiting to respond and that might be
that the database is in San Francisco or
it might be
thank you there's a lot of reasons okay
well the point is is that you can't just
wait for it to respond there's a big
difference between what happens inside
your CPU inside your memory and what
happens when you go to something outside
of that if you go to a disk or if you go
to a network if you have to do a TCP
connection to a different server even if
it's in your same hosting center then
you're talking about millions of clock
cycles instead of hundreds of clock
cycles or tens of clock cycles so you
can't do nothing so obviously better
software can do better than just wait
for the database to respond it can
multitask so you can have different
threads of execution running so the
question is is that the best that we can
do and I think you can look at two
popular web servers and see how they're
doing i/o and decide if what what
they're doing right and what they're
doing wrong so here's a benchmark which
is possibly not visible to you but it
shows concurrency on like the number of
concurrent clients on the web server on
the horizontal axis and on the vertical
axis it shows requests per second and so
this is engine X and Apache and what you
see is that the the engine X is is
responding faster not so much faster
twice as fast three times as fast
especially when you get to higher
concurrency who cares but the big
difference is when you look at
versus memory so again on the horizontal
axis is is the number of clients on your
server but now on the vertical axis you
have memory and
it looks great online okay so the point
is is that Apache uses tons of memory
when you start getting a lot of clients
if you have 3,000 people like connecting
to your Apache server you're using mini
megabytes of memory whereas in genexus
stays very stable it stays with a small
footprint and the question really is
what's the difference between these two
and the big difference is that Apache
uses threads for each connection and
nginx uses an event loop okay so to be a
slightly technical the first benchmark
kind of tells you that context switching
between the different threads which is
what Apache does is is not free it costs
some CPU time and the second one is that
each thread takes memory and that ends
up being a lot of memory and kind of in
the building tight little server thing
community if you want to make a little
engine X server or you want to make a
little IRC server everybody knows that
you can't use threats for connections
this is not the right way to do
concurrency the right way to do
concurrency is to have a single thread
and have an event loop so you do
something and then you're done with it
and then you do something else and
you're done with it but that requires
though is that what you do never takes
very long you have to have non-blocking
i/o so apache uses OS threads there's
other threading systems you could have
green threads or you could have
co-routines
these can help the situation very much
but it's still machinery it's still
something that
needs to be done you have to you have to
do something to create the illusion that
when you connect to the database your
program halts you don't move on to the
next line until it comes back it's an
illusion your programs not halting it's
doing all these other things but it
looks like it's halted so I say that
threaded concurrency is a leaky
abstraction it's it creates pains you
have locking problems you can you have
these memory problems it's hard to think
about it's not a very good abstraction
for what's really happening on your
computer so code like this where you
call a function and it connects to some
server and returns something from that
server as if no time has passed and then
you're going to use the result beyond
that this somehow either requires
blocking the entire process or you're
going to have to have some sort of
threading system
maybe it's co-routines but it's probably
going to require multiple execution
stacks but you could have the code like
this where you make the query to the
database and instead of waiting for the
response inside that function you give
it a callback in one form or another
when this happens you can your execution
can run right through that statement
make that request and continue doing
other things when the request comes back
millions and millions of clock cycles
later you can execute the callback
there's no machinery involved in this
all you need is a pointer to that
callback so this is how we need to do i
oh if you want very fast high
concurrency servers you have to design
them like this
mm-hmm so okay you say yeah but
everybody's talking about threads you
know my boss says that Java threads are
super cool blah blah blah why isn't
everybody doing this why should you
believe me well there's there's two
reasons I think they can be summed up in
two reasons anyway and it would be
cultural infrastructure 'el so I think
that there's a cultural bias against
doing non-blocking i/o you know your
first program that you ever do io with
is something where you enter your name
and then you get the results somebody
types that in but you block on that
function you don't do anything else and
then you print out the name so we're
taught to like demand input and we kind
of treat it the same way on on sockets
so we connect to the database and all
right give me the give me the give me
the response so people see code like
this where instead of waiting you just
give a call back and they say I can't do
that
that's that spaghetti code that's too
complicated I think we should reconsider
this I don't think it is necessarily
more complicated maybe in the simplest
cases like this but when you start
writing an IRC server it becomes very
natural to write code like this and the
other reason would be the missing
infrastructure so remember if you're on
an event loop you can never block on i/o
you can never wait for the database to
respond because you're in a single
threat if you ever wait everything else
shuts down we're in a threaded
environment you can wait occasionally or
for very long periods of time so the
problem is is that we just don't have
like libraries available to us to do
this sort of non blocking i/o so just a
couple of examples like POSIX has an
asynchronous file IO specification but
it's really hard to
find such libraries man pages often
don't state if a functions going to
access the disk or not you just don't
know which is important closures and
anonymous functions you don't have in C
so that makes writing such evented code
difficult and things like live MySQL
client don't support asynchronous
queries I think they actually might do
asynchronous queries but not
asynchronous connections and Aengus
asynchronous DNS resolution is is really
difficult to find so there are certain
solutions you might have heard of event
machine or pythons twisted or if you
come from Perl any event these are
libraries that provide such an event
loop with non-blocking sockets and it is
fairly easy to use them to create
efficient servers but I think that users
are kind of confused as how to use this
if you're using Ruby there's all of
these libraries available you have a
vent machine in here and you want to
know how do I use these other ones and
usually the answer to that is you can't
because the MySQL library for Ruby
blocks on everything so you can't just
throw that into an event loop but people
don't know that and so users really
still require some knowledge of event
loops or non-blocking i/o which almost
nobody has and so it's doesn't abstract
the problem very well but yeah luckily
JavaScript was was designed in such a
way that that it was built for an event
though the browser side JavaScript that
you have is an event loop you create a
button somebody clicks it you get a
unclick callback
this is exactly what one needs to do
event the stuff so yeah it has anonymous
functions and closures when you're on
the browser you only get one call back
at a time you're not getting multiple
callbacks and you don't need to lock
variables and the i/o is just done
through those callbacks so I think
everybody in this room who is familiar
with Java JavaScript is already kind of
prepared for writing evented servers you
don't you you don't really need to know
that much more so right so that was a
long motivation so what I want to make
is a non-blocking
infrastructure so that you can make very
highly concurrent servers and you don't
need to know about it we're going to
abstract all of the difficult
non-blocking event loop you don't need
to know about that it's just going to be
callbacks so right so so let me just
give some design goals and then I'll
give some actual practical examples of
how to build a server so first of all no
function should perform i/o to receive
disk or network information from or from
another process you have to have some
sort of callback so you can never have
that sort of function that makes some
query that return something that's not
allowed it should be low-level so I want
everything to be able to stream in and
out you never should never force the
user to buffer data and if you're
familiar with like Ruby on Rails or
something a lot of places
you to buffer data in one way or another
I don't want to make those choices for
you it's low level people can build on
top of that so if they want to buffer
their data then they can do that but at
my level at the node level it should not
make any sort of decisions like that and
similarly I shouldn't remove any
functionality at the POSIX layer so for
example have close TCP connections
everybody's shrugging but there's good
stuff to be had that everybody ignores
um and so I should also have like some
built-in support you don't want to write
everything I want you to I want it to be
low level but I think TCP and DNS and
HTTP are infrastructural protocols
they're very important and so there
should be very good support for them in
such a system and in particular with
with HTTP it should it's going to have
many features so we're going to have
chunked request chunked responses I'm
going to have keepalive and importantly
it should be you should be able to get a
request and respond to it at will so you
should be able to hang requests and this
is what you need for comet style
applications if you want to do a long
pole then you have to hang that request
and wait till you have something to tell
the user mm-hmm and finally the the API
needs to be familiar so if I'm going to
have a timer I'm going to call it set
timeout it's going to it should look
like browser JavaScript and where it's
not browser JavaScript where I'm talking
about POSIX stuff then it should use the
POSIX names that is I don't want to
reinvent what people are doing I just
kind of want to present an idealized
version of that and then finally it
should be platform independent at the
moment I don't compile on Windows but
there's no reason I can't and I hope to
okay so now now some actual examples so
note is you have to compile it so you
have to download it so there's no
binaries is what I want to say and you
there's no real dependencies other than
Python so it should be fairly easy to to
build it's not it's not very difficult
or at least it should not be okay so
here's here's your first example this
program is going to output hello after
having waited two seconds so first first
we require the SIS model which we need
to output some some data this is the
common j/s require uses the semantics
defined by command j s then we set a
timeout for 2,000 milliseconds mm-hmm
importantly the callback inside is not
done right now first we print hello
which comes after that two seconds later
world is printed out so node after the
world is printed out no two exits so
that's kind of important when there's
nothing else to do on the event loop if
there's no more timers than it exits
it's the end of the process okay so so
here's what you would do you would put
it into a file called hello world GS and
then run it with the node program and
you get hello to send kids later world
in the process exits okay mmm-hmm so now
we're going to change the hello world
program and what we'll do this time is
is we're going to go in a loop so we're
going to use the the set interval
function and we're going to loop forever
and print out a message and then what we
want when the user kills it when they
hit control-c that it prints out a
message and then exits and this is to
demonstrate the special
process object in node and the how you
set a signal handler the for the
interrupt signal the second okay so so
again we do the require we just need one
function so let's just pull it out into
a variable in the next three lines we
set up the interval which calls that
callback every 500 milliseconds right
and then the last couple lines we're
setting up a signal handler so you do
this by calling this add listener
function which is should be fairly
familiar if you're used to the Dom then
you put you you print out goodbye and
then you you exit the process so this
this process object emits events when it
receives a signal so it emits the sig
int event there it would be the same for
any other signal that that the process
might get so so this is like the dome
you just add a listener to catch what
the process is doing there's a couple of
other things on the process like the PID
the program arguments the environment
current working directory memory usage
useful things so the the way that
process emits these events is is pretty
typical for node so many objects emit
events it's kind of the the fundamental
paradigm in in in node so like for
example a TCP server would emit a
connection event every time somebody
connects and like if you have somebody's
doing an HTTP upload it would emit the
request object to admit a body event
each time you get a packet of that
upload so somebody's uploading a stream
a movie or so to your server and you get
body body body
so yeah all objects that emit events are
instances of the event in meter class mm
okay so so here's here's the first TCP
server example so we're going make a TCP
server it's going to listen on port 8000
and then when somebody connects we're
going to send the the peer a message
we're going to say hello and then we're
going close to the connection so a very
simple TCP server so we have to require
the TCP module that's what we do in the
first line and then we create a server
object s and we that's a TCP server and
then we add a listener for the
connection event and we get this object
C from from the connection event that's
that's our connection we send it hello
we close and then finally we have to
start it listening on port 8000 so if if
we tried that then we would start the we
would put that code in this server Jas
and you can tell that to localhost
at a port 8000 and you get hello and
then the the server closes the
connection okay so we can simplify this
a little bit so the the connection
listener does it you don't need to call
this add listener you can just pass it
to the constructor and so so we can
simplify this program until just a
couple lines by doing this so file i/o
and notice non-blocking this is
something that's usually very hard to do
and note it's quite hard not to do which
is good I mean the the way that you
should be doing things should be easy in
the way you shouldn't be doing things
should be difficult okay so so what
we're going to do is we're going to
look at the last time somebody modified
EDC password so first we require the
POSIX module which has all of our file
i/o operations and we pull out this stat
function we require our puts function
get that from the sis module and then we
call stat on EDC password and it returns
a province which I'll talk more about
and then we add a call back to the
promise which gets called when when the
stat operation was complete and then
finally we print out the the modified
time so the these these promise objects
are pretty common all the file
operations return a promise and so a
promise is is an event emitter which
which emits a success or an error event
so if you do some file operation you
don't want to block because that's going
to be a long time you can't just shut
down your server while you spin the disk
so you send off this request to the to
the disk ok tell me what time that that
file was modified I'm going to go do
other things and then eventually it
comes back and it says success I got the
answer for you here it is
or error so the the promise dot add
callback was was just API sugar for for
promise at this nurse first success okay
so we're getting progressively more
complicated now we're going to do an
HTTP server we have to require the the
HTTP module and we create a HTTP server
object and the callback for this which
is called on each request gives you a
request object in a response object so
then we send that the header the the 200
success code and content type text plane
and we send body hello send body world
and then we finished the response this
is slightly more complicated than if you
were at the narwhal talk before Tom
promotes the the J SGI specification
this is more complicated than that but
it's it's for a good reason
J SGI requires you to Iraq to rap it's
it's the same thing you have a function
and then you return the result so all
the processing happens in a single
function which as I said at the
beginning is something we want to avoid
if you have to connect to the database
then you don't want to you don't want to
have to respond in one function now I
think that there's some ways to do that
with with J SGI but i like this i think
it's it's simple enough so let's let's
try this out so we put the the code into
HTTP server j yes
we're uncurl on it and we get hello
world
okay now slightly more complicated we're
going to do the same thing we're going
to have an HTTP server which outputs
hello world but instead of outputting at
all at once it's going to output hello
and then it's going to output world two
seconds later so what we do is we put a
set timeout in there so we wait for 2000
milliseconds in the the request callback
so you might wonder like okay who cares
why would anybody want to do this but
this is important because while the
server doesn't shut down when when the
set timeout is called
it doesn't say set timeout it's not
asleep you're not sleeping for two
seconds and not doing anything else
you're serving requests so here's a
request here's a request here's a
request and then suddenly okay that
one's done that one's done that one's
done this is the exact behavior that
you'd need for comet style application
if you need to do a long pole you have
to be able to hang requests in an
efficient way and this demonstrates how
you can do that this isn't the right way
to do a long pole thing but it
demonstrates that you can hang requests
so let's try it out we put into a file
HTTP server to call it with node run
curl we get hello two seconds later we
get world a streaming web server okay we
can also use we can also call programs
with node one would hope so we can do
that with the Cissy XE command of course
this also returns a promise because it's
something that doesn't happen
immediately it doesn't happen in memory
but you know if you do LS / that might
have to spin the disk and so there's
some time that happens between the time
that that starts and the time that that
finishes so we have to have a callback
so we we add a callback to the promise
object which is returned from sista XE
and then we output the output okay so
but I told you before that I never would
force people to buffer data and that
just buffered the data so there's also a
lower-level way to call sub process to
call it to make a child process where
you can stream the data through through
the standard i/o so you can stream that
if you're you LS on a huge directory you
don't want to buffer all of that data in
memory you want to stream it to the to
the to the parent process and pars it
and handle it do whatever with it but
hopefully not buffer it so this is a
simple form of inter process
communication so this is an example of
that where we're going to launch the cat
program like the UNIX cat program which
whatever you you send to it it just
sends the same thing back and so we
create the child process in line 3
we add a listener for output so every
time that there's some output it calls
that that callback and then in the last
couple lines we write data to the cat
process and so that's sending that hello
world and line eleven and twelve to the
standard in of the cat process and then
finally we call closed which closes the
standard end of the cat process and cat
terminates when it's standard in is is
complete okay so we can Street we can
create sub processes we can create child
processes and stream data in and out of
out of them okay so so now I have a demo
for you I wrote an IRC server in node
just a hack really but just to
demonstrate what you can do so maybe
this will work maybe this won't work but
let's let's try to go to IRC no js' dot
org and go on to the node.js channel
okay so so I have my my terminal here
I'm actually logged into the server so
well first of all I'm going to connect
to the server hopefully it's still
running and it hasn't crashed
okay so so now I'm connected and I I
will join the OGS
okay so so if if people did that you can
see people talking so so this this IRC
server is is running on node this is an
IRC client of course what I want to do
is actually show yes I want to I also
have a repo library a read eval print
loop and so since we have an event loop
we can add all sorts of io to this this
is one process but we can add a repo to
it without thinking about it because
what we do is we do all the on our event
loop we we do all the connections we
send all the messages we come back and
then we can do the repo things if we
wanted to add an HTTP server to that
that would also be possible all in the
same process just by going around the
event loop and since nothing blocks we
can just add as much IO as we want to so
I show you the repo now
kind of
okay so it's running on screen so I'm
just going to open the screen
there it is okay so this is the ircd
repo thing and so what I can do is is I
have total control over the IRC server
so for example I can kill some of these
users off
yeah okay
I have full control I could also make
people like say things
okay anyway the point is we have a we
have a repo to to the IRC server and of
course if I just control see it then
everybody will go away and they're
offline now because the IRC server is
gone and if I turn it back on then it's
just there okay so so that's my my demo
okay yeah so so check out the the code
if you want it's it's just 400 lines or
so I think this demonstrates that node
abstracts the real problem of writing an
IRC server away because if you look at
the code of that it's just okay somebody
connects okay I have a list of users
okay I send this user that message it's
it's really quite easy to follow in my
humble opinion whereas if you try to sit
down and write an IRC server say in Ruby
I think you'll find it very difficult
okay I guess who can use event machine
and you might find it okay but I think
that this really abstracts the the the
problem of writing a concurrent server
so if you want to throw together say a
message queue demon startup node type
out a hundred lines of JavaScript and
there's your message queue demon that
that does whatever specific thing that
you need it to do okay so so just
briefly uh I talked about the internal
design of node so note is not some big
monolithic app it's it's a bunch of C
libraries that are kind of hacked
together in various ways so the v8 is
not a little seed library it's a huge C
library that's by Google of course the
Lib Evie event loop and Libby IO thread
pool are a really nice little libraries
and they're both written by marked
layman there's a HTTP parser which is
quite advanced it could do all sorts of
streaming sort of things that's by me
and a socket library by me too and then
a you you DNS is is a DNS resolver which
is important so the way that I do this
is
there's a lot of system calls that you
might do if you have to access the file
system those system calls those POSIX
system calls can block and so what I do
is I have a thread pool underneath
everything and I say ok I want to do
this system call I want to read a
directory I pack it up and then I send
it off to the thread pool it does stuff
and then it comes back signal handlers
are usually asynchronous from the rest
of your execution stack and this this
thread pool thing these things are kind
of asynchronous from the main nodejs
event loop and so they have to notify
they have to be marshaled back into the
main event loop you have to say ok wait
your turn alright now we can process the
signal handler you can't just do it
immediately when the result comes from
the event loop you can't just say stop
everything we're going to do this you
have to say ok all right now we can
process you and we I do this by by using
a pipe from the thread pool in and from
signal handlers in and you can select on
that pipe another thing that I did is
I'm worried about what happens if you
pipe a huge file into node so say this
this file is 200 megabytes and has a
list of domain names and you want to
look them all up so each line is a
domain name and you want to do dns
resolution on them but you can't block
the dns resolution or else it's going to
be really slow what you want to do is
read it and stream it into your node
process read the lines do the DNS
lookups and this should all be on the
same event level so the problem is is
that in UNIX or in any POSIX system the
standard EDD file descriptor is going to
refer to a file and you can't select on
files you can't add them to your event
loop you can't just read from them
because that's going to block
so what you do is you create a pumping
thread and you have a pipe and so you do
these blocking reads from the file pump
them into the pipe a which goes into the
main application and in this way you can
stream data into the the server in a
non-blocking way with just one extra
thread these are the sort of things that
you might have to do know about if you
were going to write this yourself you
don't have to do that it's under the
it's down below the the API that the
users deal with if you're interested
look in the source directory at the
coupling okay so so what's next I have
to fix some some API issues there's
various things that are very kind of
ugly I want to have more modularity I
want to have break up the libraries into
DLL so that the the coronoid process is
very small and that if you need the HTTP
server you would load a DLL to some
shared object to to get the HTTP parser
for example I'm going to include some
libraries for like MySQL and Postgres
into the core distribution I need to
improve performance that's always an
issue there's there's a some low-hanging
fruit that I know about that we can that
we can pick and make it faster TLS
support is on its way and then finally I
would like to do some sort of web worker
like thing which would probably just
extend the the child process object so
that you can create processes and kind
of do IPC between them in a in a nice
way so right now the version is 0.1
point 17 I will release 0.2 which will
be kind of the first version that I
would hope that other people would use
at the moment I think it's a bit hacky
and if your experimental then please use
it but
if not then wait for 0.2 and I think
that will be good because I will freeze
the API or at least some of it and so
you can kind of build on it with some
confidence that I won't change it out
from underneath mmm okay so yes any
questions
so the the question is if like if you
make changes to the source file well it
will it load in those changes
no but Felix and I have been hacking on
this a bit this weekend it's something
I'd like to add yes
so the question is what do I do with
blocking rights when you have a socket
there's a right buffer in the kernel and
you can only write so much data to the
right buffer before it gets filled up
this kernel can't push out all the data
to the network as fast as it wants to
there's some buffer that that can
possibly fill up so if you're streaming
a file out of the socket to somewhere
else then that can block in node it
doesn't block it buffers the data it
will allocate data internally if you do
that and what you could do is get a
callback win that buffer when the kernel
buffer drains so what you can do if you
want to stream a file to somebody you
start sending it and then you send a say
a megabyte which may fill up the buffer
may not fill up the buffer and then you
wait till it drains and then you send
another megabyte and so in this way you
can stream data the the right buffer
will never fill up what will happen is
all allocate memory so in in user space
so so rights don't block
yes
so the question is what is my stance on
common j/s so common je s I think has a
lot of good proposals so the module
system I'm using there's a binary
proposal and there's a package proposal
which which look very good at the moment
commonjs has only ratified I think the
the module proposal and the assert this
testing library proposal so it doesn't
define things like IO so I think those
discussions will be ongoing I think
there's some people who want it more in
a blocking state I want it more in a
vented State and so we'll fight it out
over the next couple months or so yes
a little bit I would like to have more
money for it
writing your own open-source project
requires a lot of effort and yeah it
needs funding